we are going to discuss the secret life
of pawns but today we're going to start
our lesson about bone structure I think
that pawn structure is probably one of
the most important things to knowing
chests so many pawn structures we have
for example double pawns we have triple
bonds we have isolated pawns we have
porn chains pretty much every typical
typical opening that we have in the
chess game is defined by the pawn
structures so if you think about because
you know I can probably take off all the
pieces of the board and show you a pawn
structure and you immediately
immediately will know you know the
opening that was played for example if I
do let's say I put the pawns like this
then we know that this is the Sicilian
dragon and and so on and so on
so for instructions are definitely very
very important okay so today we are
going to discuss some of the strengths
and weaknesses that we have in pawn
structures and I would like to do that
by giving to a few games a few example
games the first one we are going to look
at a game from 1998 a left pull of the F
scale was a very strong grandmaster
against a URI the conn-young so let's
see what happens so 9f to happen in the
game in night of 6 and c4 we start with
the smooth water which we call the ready
defense very flexible mobile though
probably by the way probably this move
Knight of three is one of the most
flexible moves that we have in chess
because why it still does not reveal his
his intentions or what kind of an OP
opening to play for example if exactly
something like c5 then Y can play E for
suddenly with an supposed to the the
Sicilian if if black plays something
like d5
then we might be transposing to the
Queen's Gambit install things like that
so basically Knight to f3 is one of the
most flexible moves that we have in
chess the first move
so knight Knight f6 was was played black
is is pretty much copying from from
white and saying okay well if you are
playing flexible I'm going to do the
same thing
c4 b6 and now
g3 so white likes to finish out his
bishop to on g2 the faint shadows
nowadays are very very popular because
we understand it on the chess board we
have those two major diagonals this one
at the h1 aa8 and we also have the a 1h
8 so this is why we like to fetch it our
bishop also it creates it makes the King
feel safer while when the bishop is next
to him so Bishop to e6 and our white
played d4 now so it's on spos'n to this
kind of the Queen's Indian defense which
could have started with it were the most
d4 Knight f6 c4 e6 and then Knight f3
and then b6 so as you can see this is a
transposition this move d4 allows black
to play this move Bishop to b4 check
which was played in a game if white
wanted to prevent this this move Bishop
before and what can actually castle
short I used to plate like this a few of
my games and then it basically it was
tricks this this option of black to play
a bishop before however what black can
usually play you can play something like
C 5.1 to c5 to try to prevent white from
playing d4 so this is just one of the
variations so in the game progressed to
play d4 immediately bishop before check
well we always have this debate or how
do we how do we defend from this check
there are lots of options here what can
either play Bishop d2 you can also play
92 usually denied
does not go to c3 anymore because if the
knight goes to c3 we know that the
bishop is gonna take the knight and the
pawn is going to take the bishop and
although white gets the two push of
advantage now White has those double
pawns and this is something that we
don't like to see it's an inferior the
pawns are just troubling each other so
Bishop before was played Bishop to d2 is
the most is not safe straightforward
approach Bishop takes d2 and queen takes
on d2 again some people would like to
take here with a knight on D too
however most fashionable is to take with
a queen because the knight will likely
to find a better spot on c3 just Castle
was played Knight to c3 as you can see
why it's finished up his development now
what should black do well black has lots
of lots of options you can either play
d5 immediately you can play more of a
positional game put all his pawns on on
dark squares in this game let me use
this move Knight to e4 and the idea of
94 is pretty simple black wants to
exchange all the pieces and for example
Knight takes e4 Bishop takes e4 and now
this Bishop is basically counter
attacking this Bishop on g2 and it's
pretty pretty difficult to move it away
from here so let's say white can castle
here and now it's gonna be very
difficult for us to move the bishop away
we will have to move the knight somehow
and then exchange your bishop and
usually people who vanchat of the bishop
we don't really like to exchange this
bishop so it creates some headache for
us so in this in this game Paula gave
she decided to play this move Queen to
d3 he said okay I'm not gonna take the
knight I'm just gonna move my queen at
the same time attacking the knight f5 is
played in this game and this is this is
a very typical maneuver this is kind of
a pawn structure
defne this not
in an in the Indian and Queen's Indian
we know that black usually it doesn't
play d5 because it does not want to
block his Bishop so the bishop here is
much much more active in this case
okay so fi was played and again we need
to fight this this not only for white
played this brave move Knight to e5 so
so what to do here with black I mean
black is in a kind of a cross role he
needs to figure out okay well this
Knight is being attacked I'm gonna lose
a pawn so so what do I do
I mean if the knight takes here on c3
he's going to lose the bishop on on b7
black is not again black does not want
to play d5 because that's gonna create
lots of witnesses on dark squares so
black black decides to use tactics and
he plays this move Knight to c5 and the
idea is that he retreats with an eye to
c5 and now is attacking the Queen on d3
you know what to do we don't have time
to take the bishop on b7 so White has
put a pretty much no choice but he had
to take the pawn on c5 Bishop takes on
g2 and now white played the roof to g1
one of our members in the audience feels
the pain for white it looks like it's
pretty horrible for white right white
loss the castle white lows the bishop
here on g2 I mean what's going on how
how does black get so much so much
advantage in doping but this is not the
end of the world because actually
White's pieces are pretty active a
pretty active and right now black and
decided to retreat with this Bishop to
c6 okay so what to do here with white
what would be our next move I guess the
question will be do we take this pawn b6
do we do with the fan this pawn on c5 do
we ignore this this threat so how to
proceed here
Castle queenside and so your idea is to
just sacrifice the pond yeah perfect
very good you're playing just a
grandmaster
so castle multitasking we defend the
king we activate the rook and and now
black needs to make a choice I mean what
to do and then we put some a lot of
pressure on the d7 pawn so that's
exactly what happened
like I said night and two delayed this
this capture on c6 and he played Queen
to f6
the idea was probably because he wants
to get the night away from here only
five but now white again again ignores
this threatened on the pawn on c5 and
plays f4 therefore was playing in the
game and finally black decided okay well
my position is starting to be pretty bad
so at least I can at least I will take a
pawn to conceive five however now White
has this nice and amazing technique he
can use well although our night here on
the on only five looks beautiful well we
need to come up with a plan and the plan
was although we cannot take on here on
d7 and now I decided to capture here on
c6 now if that takes you with a knight
then the d7 pawn falls and after list
and the c7 pawn and everything becomes
weak so black decides to recapture with
their pawn yes
that is a very ugly construction indeed
but black is black is upon up right but
we don't we don't really feel this so
what to do then why to move Knight to a4
okay 934 was suggested and okay that's
an idea and so what if I play Knight a
six
okay we can also go a for yes please
yeah Queen d7 okay yeah that's that's
possible yeah so the question is do we
go after those pawns or we don't go
after those pawns yes please d4 you like
no those pawns yeah that's the question
do we do we get to come here and start
picking those pawns up one by one or
what do we know them and Paulo Jeff's
key decided that those pawns are very
very weak and also if they really really
restrict this Nidal on b8 so yes we can
play something like Knight to a4 however
now the knight can come to a6 which
would which would black would play
anyway and yes you can play Queen d7
well wait a second now we're gonna have
some trouble here maybe something like
Ruby 8 or all night default is going to
come in rook FD 8 really it's going to
basically activate the opponent's pieces
so I'm not really sure exactly but I
think rook FD 8 maybe take maybe night
to before and we might lose the a to
pawn so suddenly we have to calculate a
lot so in this position why decides to
ignore those pawns and just to play e4
just get more more space if black takes
the pawn on e4 that's that's gonna be
pretty bad right because the knight
takes only four I'm gonna fork you and
I'm gonna fold the Queen and then upon
here on c5 as well as creating this
accident opponent only six so black
decides not to take on e5 and he he
plays Knight to a6 and now II five is
played in the game fixing up those those
pawns and now II six is gonna be forever
a weakness Queeny Queeny 7 was played
and now it is time to start picking up
the spawns so Queen f3 attacking the the
pawn on on c6 night before he does not
help because I will just play simply a
three so I cannot defend this this pawn
so black had to play Queen to e8 okay so
White's to move what to do next
okay g4 as possible yeah
pawn to b3 okay
that's also possible mm-hmm so your plan
is is to double the Rose or d-file okay
good anybody else so let's let's compare
those those three plans first of all if
I play this move b3 I don't really see
right now the reason why to play this
move because the the pawn on c4 is not
getting attacked the pawn on b2 is not
getting attacked so maybe in the future
I will play BT but maybe I want who
knows and for example you will see in
the game that one of the reasons why
black wouldn't play night before is
because white restricted his Knight with
a three now if I put if I play both this
move a3 and b3 then BT will become a
witness so I might want to wait with
this move g3 is another very very
lucrative option g-form sorry G foal is
another option but here again sometimes
we need to look at the board and say you
know think prophylactically what does
mine what is my opponent wants to do and
you will see that it really black
doesn't have much of a plan here so by
playing g4 you might check a check here
checkmate him on the G file but you
might also give black DD the option to
get some counter play or of his own so
in this case opening it immediately is
not his nuts are good and
so in this case I would always always
teach my students to ask themself watch
my worst piece and how can I improve it
my queen is good my rock is good my
knight might find a way a spot for
himself to transfer to right now I don't
really see a good square for the night
so why does decide to double up the
rooks and he starts with a stroke
so it phase rule - G - same same way but
same idea same plan but different way so
Raja - was played rook f7 a crook G - D
- and that that's it the black the black
is completely completely restricted all
of these pieces don't don't have any
penny spaces no no places so the rooks
can have come to the D file the Queen
has to stay here on the a to defend the
c6 pawn deny is not doing much so
position is speaking this is almost lost
you just just took place such a position
is Pele suffrage for for for black you
just wait for the death sentence to come
so h6 was played in the in the game the
black is trying to make some useful
moves and Knight 84 so now I'm proving
my knight putting some pressure here on
c5 just in case King to h7 was played
and now 83 so a so so so again just
improving the lid a bit by bit
Knight is going to attack here the pawn
is just hitting the night so the knight
cannot move anywhere and so on and so on
route to rook to b8 o Spain okay so
what's next so it looks like you know we
improved our pieces but whether we how
do we break through
okay interesting idea kouen h5 is
definitely a move that I would consider
in the game
now you have to ask yourself two
questions when you really come up with a
plan you always have trusted of what
what happens if I forget another move
right so that's say I do put my queen on
h5 well what what if that doesn't
doesn't doesn't do anything it's not a
zooms one let's say it plays like
something like rook c8 or okay it just
waits in that case you might be saying
that you're kind of pinning the here but
I don't see that we can't we can't
really play rook d7 because I think you
can take with the Queen rook takes and
and then our work is going to take we're
gonna get two rooks four for a queen
which in this position going to bring
lots of control for black in addition
after playing move like queen h5 you
want to look at what happens if black
moves this rope well do you really want
to exchange your Queens in this position
and the answer is no that's correct
because he has no space we are attacking
so we want to leave the Queen's on the
board so so interesting idea but not
queen h5 yes okay so we go going back to
the others the same idea h2 n g4 can be
played in this game again if I do that
I'm kind of afraid that he's going to
take and get some counter play maybe
Queen f8 afterwards and it some kind of
well on f4
yeah I just King h8 probably yeah so it
might it might work if I play like h3
if I bring both rooks here on the H file
G file then play g4 but then well who
knows maybe doesn't even take us it's a
bit a bit risky yes very good again
what's a worse piece so now I mean in
this position and the only piece we can
improve is to try to improve the Queen
but not on the Queen side but looking at
his weaknesses and he is lots of them so
why played Queen to c3 Queen see it was
played and now Queen to a5 so attacking
the knife looking at the spawned okay at
this point now really black duck has
some troubles here okay so again black
cannot do cannot do much there any rook
move is not not gonna be so good by the
way white has a threat here for example
you black plays something like rookie 7
why I can probably play something like
rook to d8 Queen takes rook takes but I
also give this night so black played
look to be three and what's the idea
well now if white plays rook to d8 then
black is playing to play something like
Queen b7 and okay we do control them
although all of the back rank but then
there are some some ideas that black
might make his group to have to e he
might then play Queen to to b3 some some
tactics going on here so the simplest
way for why it was was to say okay well
I improved all my pieces but I can't
improve my pieces at him anymore so I
just want to get rid of my opponent's
best pieces and right now he got worried
about the stroke so the move that he
played was simply rook to beat d3 who DT
was play the rook takes rook takes he
has to exchange and queen to b7
okay so again we want to improve my my
pieces now I'm less worried about
there's no rogue here but if I try to to
bring my rook to the eight then again
maybe black is gonna try to even to
sacrifice his his Knight and trying to
perpetual check us so white needs to
make just this nice little move came to
see to now we proved the King rook is
seven and now finally go to d8 now pay
attention that in all of those moves
white could have taking on c5 but I
don't have to I mean why would I take I
can I can do it anytime I want and
really it's a it's a full black he needs
to think about well what happens every
time he is to calculate what happens if
it takes me so just like playing around
so move to the eighth and now King g6
was played in the game not so sure maybe
just maybe just black was out of moves
okay what to do here and what would
white so we improve the overall pieces
what to do next
do we take on c5 we don't take on c5
what to do next okay so you say - to
take on c5 yeah this this is this is an
interesting option now nine takes Knight
takes Queen takes you definitely you go
to attack my work you're going to attack
the pawn here going to attack the the
pawn here that's that's that's a good
option but again let's let's go and
let's let's look at this from blacks
prospective there's going to flip the
ball for just a moment just think about
black just played the his last move King
g6 here's nothing to do I mean he is
Knight cannot move his Queen cannot move
anywhere the rook cannot move anywhere
he's just gonna go back and forth of the
King so yes we can't take on c5 but it
might make give black some extra options
right
so why decides not to take on c5 but how
do we use now the fact that all his all
these pieces if you look at here the
Queen here and the night are on the
Queen side not in the game suddenly the
King feels alone here on g6 correct so
why just play Queen to d2 bringing in
the Queen and now I want to open up the
the King side so Queen d2 was played
king of king of seven and now Queen to
d1 the threat is obviously Queen to h5
and then g6 I take and it's almost a
mate black played King g6 has to defend
this pawn and finally g4
the the planet we're waiting for
fireworks fhg for was played but this is
almost lost and now here even if f5 take
take and black did play g6 but they
actually design here because probably
just Queen to f8 and what is so amazing
about this position is just look at look
at his pieces I mean the Queen and all
those all those pawns really are really
really restricted and that that is all
the whole point of the game is it really
don't even they have to touch it right
it's like they're in prison right right
so now it's not we like to to break
anything in the a king site so that's so
that's a nice illustration how really
triple pawns or double points are our
weakness however they are not always a
witness so right now what I would like
to show you another example but you'll
see that the double points might be even
a strength which is called quite strange
this game is pretty pretty famous played
by Nigel short with vs. Jan Timman in
1991 very very strong and famous two
grandmasters Evo was played by by Nigel
short Knight of 6 so we have the other
kind defense giving lesson as popular
nowadays it just gives lots and lots of
space for white he 5 is the main line in
Knight to d5
d4 was played in d6 and pretty much in
this position white needs to figure out
a plan there are lots and lots of moves
here a wife can either push c4 to get it
gained another tempo on the other night
white can
take of these six I can play something
like a four-night of three Bishop c4
Plaza lots of options what I used to
play here I used to I used to just push
see four for myself but in this game
Nigel decided to play Knight to f3 also
put the natural move develop with the
piece g6 again we see a faint chatter in
this in this game Bishop c4 now Knight
to b6 back and Bishop to b3 nothing much
going on Bishop g7 and in this position
after Bishop g7 why I decided to play
Queen e2 and why do I need to play this
move Queen e2 because black wants to
take only five and again if let's say if
I Castle pawn takes and if I take with a
pawn take take well the space advantage
in in this and in this kind of an
endgame difficult if you can call it an
endgame is not felt as much 96 and
actually this pawn might become very
vulnerable after Bishop g4 as well so so
why I decided to keep the Queen's on the
board and by playing Queen three - so
Quinn to e2 was played 96 short gas or
short Castle and h3 a great prophylactic
move because if we don't play h3 the
bishop is going to come to g4 for
example if we just play Knight c3 we
have to be careful because now Bishop g4
and suddenly all of those pawns are
hanging it's very difficult for us to
defend everything it's pretty much like
getting a perfect move the defense like
within those pawns on e4 and Defour and
then pushing it just too much so h3 had
to be played
a five a four so we can't we cannot
allow black to gain more space with a
for some people some players prefer to
play the subtle eight three the this is
kind of the difference also in the oil
op as we see this or the the Italian
game sometimes white black plays a three
or a four it's kind of a it's a metal of
taste so a you for was played completely
block completely fixing the a5 pawn pawn
takes pawn takes and black decides to
exchange a few pieces by playing Knight
to d4 94 we have to take Queen takes on
d4 the pawn hero only five is hanging so
we have to play rook e1 so far so so
good so far it's pretty forced and now
black does this move pawn to e6 this
move is a little bit strange I would say
this would definitely not be my first
candidate all of this move a c6 but in
my opinion probably what happened is
that black was afraid of this movie six
of them white but if it was up to me I
would probably just develop the bishop
probably the bishop to to a5 or
something like that I don't see why to
be scared of ecigs too much because if
you try to play this immediately I can
probably just take everything and my
pawn here on earth to might be hanging
defending it will not help because it'll
be to somebody hanging so I think this
this move is six really was one of the
one of the reasons why black lost the
game so now look at look at this this
Bishop on c8 being punished for no
reason
okay sir Luke see it was easy go
straight and now Knight to d2 we need to
choose now the knife can go either to d2
or or c3 a white prefers to put the
knight on f3 in order to really defend
this pawn on d5 Knight to d5 is played
Knight to f3 attacking the Queen Queen
to c5 Queen went to before and now white
had a very clear strategy white wanted
to play something like Queen to h4 then
90 g5 either immediately or maybe first
Bishop to h6 and attack the black king
because we usually know that when we
have such a such a pawn structure when
we have the de-spawn d5 it not only
controls more space but it allows all of
our pieces suddenly to attack on the
Kings side okay so back to move how how
should you on team and no playing is
this this plan or this try to play
against this plan correct yes Queen
before not only by preventing display
with Queen h4 but also I want to
exchange a few pieces it's gonna make my
life much much easier okay falou board
so how to how to continue with white
obviously we don't we don't exchange
that we don't want to exchange the
Queen's but we also want to keep
attacking so what would be a way for us
to make sure that we hold the Queen's on
the board this ship to d5 interesting so
you want to take the pond the night so I
guess I have to take you the Queen takes
d5 that's possible but then probably
maybe Bishop e6 again black that gets a
lot of condo play Bishop e6 Bishop a5
and it wins the rock to da torre eight
and suddenly although all of his pieces
are pointy for going to lose the the
bishop and then well you take the night
with an operatic with it
with a queen probably Queen to back this
will be probably at the draw fur if you
go okay so Queen e2 here interesting
with the idea of wish of D - hmm I
wonder if I can now if I can play 94
after Queen e2 or if I can play
something B C's Bishop Bishop h6 d 5
yeah so Bishop d5 I will take Queen
takes and again yes we are pawn up but
the black is going to play Bishop e6 Oh
Bishop f5 getting all this I think
probably Bishop f5 attacking in c2 the
route d8 coming with the tempo and lots
and lots of compensation black gets for
this point so why I decided not not to
allow this Bishop to come out but
there's one more move that prevents the
exchange of Queens yes almost 94 94 then
I can play c5 which you're close
yeah
okay Bishop c4 yes very good
now the problem Bishop c4 is that now
black played a night to be six so it
almost looks like we have to move the
bishop away and exchange the Queens but
no now why it makes one of the best
moves in the game let's see if we can
fight what's the move for white exactly
b3 also not only defending the bishop
but preparing Bishop 283 so suddenly
white is much battle here and so black
the sides ok well at least I will get
the [ __ ] about what he went with a
knight back so Knight b6 Knight takes e4
and pawn takes e4 ok so what do we have
here
so yes we get we damage the pawn
structure we destroy that pretty much
that we had a nice pawn chain now we had
we have this there's those double pawns
a for pawn is weak yes it looks pretty
bad but on the other hand now we can
continue with our plan the plan that we
had on the Kings side there is not much
of a contemplated a question that black
and create here and on those pawns so
let's see what happens so b3 Knight
takes Knight takes rook e8 was played to
prevent Bishop e3 ruled e1 improving the
rook Queen c5 Queen h4 yeah so again as
you can see in this position blacks
blacks pieces are very very restricted
taking on taking only five years
obviously just too dangerous you're
gonna weaken all of your dark squares
probably teh
I wonder if I can play Knight g5 as well
but take take my could probably play
something like other okay three would be
one with the idea of Bishop b2 and those
are not good news here I call it the
cheese structure all those holes so
black decides to to keep to keep playing
not to take this pawn it plays b6 pretty
logical idea he wants to develop his
Bishop Bishop III queen c6 and Bishop to
h6 again if black gives up this Bishop
on g7 we know that if we give up this
this the dragon the dragon head then we
will will be a cheese so again he
decides to play Bishop to h8 it's a very
typical typical maneuver by the way for
for somebody to to save the bishop like
the special h8 I know to take out the
from this pin so luckily for black his
rook here I was only eight so Bishop F 8
h8 was played and now white is playing
this move rook to d8 again just
improving the the rest of his pieces
there should be seven obviously cannot
take the rogue because of checkmate so
if the bishop to b7 rook a to d1 okay
wonderful now all of my pieces as I like
to say they are all employed
unemployment is almost zero well the
King is maybe over here on g1 is
unemployed but just just for now he's
looking for a job he's in between jobs
to be could be called natural
unemployment there's as far as I
remember sir Luke Rudi 8 ok d1 and now
again so the black doesn't have any plan
so what can black do here I cannot move
any one of my my rocks count over this
this bishop
I wonder if blacken can try to take on
on a four there's probably some some
kind of a some kind of somebody's gonna
fall off the Queen takes 84 I think the
threat is Queen is seven now pretty
powerful threat so black decides okay
well I need to exchange the dis bishop
otherwise may there's so many made
threats of Bishop g7 was played and now
rook eight to d7 y changing changes his
mind he says okay well I wanna I don't
see the point of exchanging the rocks
now rook look f8 taked and King takes
rook 1 to d4 okay it's an elevator rook
a to the 8th Queen to f6 check King to
g8 okay so the game is almost lost but
we still have to win it somehow so how
do we do it as one of the it's one of
the most popular themes nowadays as well
as played by alpha zero lots of engines
and we play this movie h4 so now the
plan is bringing the there the deponent
to h6 and just checkmating here on g7
there's nothing much that they can do
the only the only options the back and
then they can choose from our playing h6
or oh5 now the problem with h6 is that
it doesn't really stop h5 i can still to
h5 and my castle is completely ruined
so black decided to play h5 okay so
definitely white white is the one who
dominates this disposition but again we
need to to find to find a way a way to
win this now unfortunately we cannot
push g4 here as we did in in the last
game because if we do the Queen here is
going to take on f3 we're going to lose
a piece we are going to exchange the
Queen's not too good for us so this is
why this game is so so famous why to
move and you need to find a plan how to
win this I gotta be careful with 9595 is
a checkmate one move Queen to h2 and
what's the plan oh yes and that's the
correct plan remember we want to employ
all of our pieces hundred percent
employment so the plan is even if it's
not an endgame we want to put this King
here on h6
puttin putting almost soon as I came
possible and they just check my three on
g7
that's exactly what Nigel is doing
he plays King to h2 and we're there is
no defense for four black yeah his
business are completely restricted I
mean he can try to take on maybe if he
takes on a four but then I assume that
there is 95 or g4 might be coming oc7
will be hanging as well
if you hang c7 then I'm gonna bring my
other up to d7 as well
so King h2 and let's see the end of the
game Rock to CC it was played King to GT
move to see C to e 8 and then came to f4
the march of the King Bishop CA it's
finally black realizes what's going on
here if it's Bishop c8 but that does not
help it's just too late so white plays
came to g5 and gentiemen designs here
simply because well even if you take the
Queen just King h6 and
that's it going to just have a next move
so if you see this this position if we
go just a few moves backward creating
those double points will was not such it
was not such a bad idea and in the
damaging of bone structures sometimes it
is good when it helps our plan
eventually okay right well thank you so
much for for joining us for this pawn
and games
[Music]